oh really
the results of tonight's election i Neal
Jack acting returning officer for the
Blackpool north and Cleveland
constituency declare that the total
number of votes for each candidate is as
follows close Susan Jane commonly known
as Sue Liberal Democrat 747 votes
Maynard
Paul Christopher Conservative Party
candidate twenty thousand two hundred
and fifty five votes royal Duncan John
the Green Party 381 votes web
Christopher Paul commonly known as Chris
Labour Party eighteen thousand two
hundred and thirty two votes white bull
Martin UK Independence Party
you kept one thousand three hundred and
ninety two votes the rejected ballot
papers are as follows
did not bear the official mark zero
voting for more than one candidate
fifteen writing or mark by which the
kept the voter could be identified to
unmarked or void for uncertainty 42 I
declare that poor Christopher Maynard is
duly elected as the Member of Parliament
the Blackpool north and clearly
constituency
[Applause]
Thank You Neil it's a pleasure to be
reelected for a third time to represent
the people of Blackpool north and
Seabreeze and to receive more vote that
I've ever received before in a general
election can I thank all the counters
and all the people who've organized
tonight's count for expediting the
process did always a tense and difficult
process and they've done an exceptional
job tonight and I'm very grateful I
thank the police the presiding officers
all the polling station Clark's have
done so much over the course of the day
not just to ensure that the election
runs well but to keep us all safe and
secure in these uncertain times can I
rededicated to work on behalf of the
people of block for Norton cleave leaves
and for the good of the country in the
years to come we do not know what the
outcome of tonight's election will be
but I know for certain that our
continued represent every single
constituent in Blackpool north and
peevly's no matter who they voted for
tonight